good morning John
I'm still sick
this is annoying
the thing that I've noticed now that I've had this happening for like two weeks
is that when you are sick
people give you advice
I've actually noticed this for years when it comes to my ulcerative colitis
a lot of people seem to have a cure
in their back pocket
if only I'd go gluten free or stop eating grains
or palio or vegan
or stop eating short train carbohydrates
or fast for three days and then eat an apple
seriously it was a whole thing
and it took like half the party for him to explain it to me
and over the years I've tried a lot of those things
and none of them worked
what worked was taking the medicine that my doctor gave to me
and then over the past week
people have been saying completely normal things to me
like get some rest man
or take it easy
stop stressing sleep more
and I've been a little bit shocked by how annoying this is
not because it is annoying like its fine
It's a totally fine thing for somebody to say
but it's tapping into this thing that I have
with my ulcerative colitis
after years of dealing with my chronic illness
that I can not cure
and having people tell me ways that I should be able to cure it
what I'm hearing is not, you know 'take it easy, we support you'
instead I'm hearing: 'I have the secret to your wellness and If only
'you had the courage and fortitude to implement it, you would no longer be sick'
and one step further from that
whats tickling by subconscious here
is this idea that my illness is my fault
I know that my chronic illness is pretty insignificant
compared with what a lot of other people are dealing with
but I think this is probably an experience that a lot of people have
when you tell me, a person who has lived with ulcerative colitis for more than a decade
that you have the secret to my wellness
I can not help but dislike you
like if that's my first impression, and sometimes it is
I'm like 'I'm out'
and look maybe this is the one weird instance in which you are the one who was right
and maybe I'm missing that opportunity
to finally make myself better
but I've heard this line so many times
with so many different facts and so many different pieces of anecdotal evidence
that all I can hear when people say this to me
is 'your illness is your fault'
because we want it to be somethings fault, right?
because if its not the fault of anything, then it has to be just weird random chance
and that's what chronic illness is
it just freaking happens
to good people and bad people and champion athletes and people who drink to much
I've dealt with my illness by allowing myself to accept it
by admitting to myself and accepting that my life is different now and my body is different now
and I have to live inside of this body
that sometimes hurts itself
science will keep marching forward
and someday maybe there will be a medicine that I can take that will control this disease
without making me sick in other ways
and yes, science shows that my behaviour does influence the expression of my disease
and so does my experience of my disease
and so I do need support from people that help me make the decisions
that my doctor says that I should make
and that I have decided for myself that I want to make
but I also can't avoid the truth that this is the body that I'm in
and I have to accept that like among the
many probabilities that were cast, that mostly came up in my favour
I rolled bad on auto-immune diseases
my brain tried to tell me over and over again that this is my fault
I have searched for every possible way
subconsciously and consciously
that this is a thing that I did to myself
and that's a crappy feeling
and its re-emphasized every time someone tells me that there's a
simple thing that I can do to make myself well
I want to say here at the end of this video
I'm doing fine, I'm not angry or frustrated
at my friends or at you
I have a loving and supportive group of people
who are fantastic in my life
and I do my best to understand that when people are saying these things
they're not trying to make me feel what I'm feeling
so I just try and accept that support for what it is
rather than how it's being expressed specifically
but if you want to be supportive of someone who's sick in your life
make sure that you recognise that it's very possible
that they are struggling right now
with this feeling that they did something to cause or to deserve the illness they have
even if objectively they understand that that's completely untrue
when we say there is an easy way out of this
and there's not
what we're making people feel
is that 'this is your fault'
when it's not.
John, I'll see you on tuesday